by now we have introduced all sorts of
pmfs for the discrete case the joint pmf
the conditional pmf given an event and
the conditional pmf of one random
variable given another and we're moving
along with a program of defining
analogous concepts for the continuous
case we have already discussed the joint
PDF and the conditional PDF given an
event the next item in our menu is to
define a conditional PDF of one random
variable given another random variable
we proceed by first looking at the
definition for the discrete case a
typical entry of the conditional PMF is
just a conditional probability but in
different notation and using the
definition of conditional probabilities
this is equal to the ratio of the joint
divided by the probability of the
conditioning event unfortunately in the
continuous case a definition of this
form would be problematic because the
event that Y takes on a specific value
is an event that has zero probability
and we know that we cannot condition on
a zero probability event however we can
take this expression as a guide on how
to define a conditional PDF in the
continuous case and this is the
definition which just mimics the formula
that we have up here notice that this
conditional PDF defined this way is
well-defined as long as the denominator
is a positive quantity let us now try to
make sense of this definition let us
first recall the interpretation of the
conditional PDF given an event a that
has positive probability we know that
the PDF is used to determine the
probability of a small interval and
similarly the conditional PDF is used to
calculate the conditional probability of
a small interval given the conditioning
event we would like to do something
similar for the conditional PDF where we
would like to take the event a to be
something like the event that Y is equal
to some particular value little
why but as we said this is problematic
because this event does not have
positive probability so instead we can
take a to be the event that y is
approximately equal to a certain value
so we're dealing with a little interval
around this value little Y which in
general would be an event of positive
probability and we can try to have a
similar interpretation let us see how
this works out so what does it mean that
Y is approximately equal to some
particular value little Y we interpret
that as follows we're told that the
random variable Y takes a value that is
within epsilon where epsilon is a small
number of a given value little Y and
given this conditioning information we
want to calculate the probability of a
small interval how do we do that
well here because this in general will
be a positive probability event we can
use the definition of conditional
probabilities and it would be equal to
the probability of both events happening
divided by the probability of the
conditioning event what is the
probability of both events happening
this is a probability of a small
rectangle in X Y space at that rectangle
the joint PDF has a certain value and
because we're integrating over that
rectangle and that rectangle has
dimensions Delta and epsilon that
probability of that small rectangle is
approximately equal to this then we need
the denominator which is the probability
of the conditional event and this is
approximately equal to the density of Y
evaluated at that point times the length
of the small interval we cancel the
absolutes
and then we notice that the ratio we
have here is what we defined as the
conditional PDF so we get this relation
times Delta so what do we see we see
the probability of a small interval is
equal to a PDF times the length of the
small interval however because we are
conditioning on Y being approximately
equal to a certain value we end up using
a corresponding conditional PDF where
the conditional PDF is defined this way
so we now have an interpretation of the
conditional PDF in terms of
probabilities of small intervals now
that we have an intuitive interpretation
of the conditional PDF we can also use
it to calculate conditional
probabilities of more general events not
just intervals and we do this as follows
in general for continuous random
variables we can find the probability
that X belongs to a certain set by
integrating a PDF over that set because
here we're dealing with a conditional
situation where were given the value of
y we use the conditional PDF instead of
the true PDF and with this way we
calculate the conditional probability
now the difficulty is that this
conditional probability is not a
well-defined quantity according to what
we did early on in this class we cannot
condition on 0 probability events but we
can get around this difficulty as
follows this quantity is well-defined
and we can use this quantity as the
definition of this conditional
probability and so we have managed to
provide the definition of conditional
probabilities given a 0 probability
event of a certain type it turns out
that this definition is sound and
consistent with everything else that we
are doing but when we are dealing with
particular problems and applications we
can generally forget about all these
subtleties that we have been discussing
here the bottom line is that we will be
treating conditional PDFs given the
value of a random variable Y just as
ordinary PDFs
but given the information that this
random variable took on a specific value
and in that conditional universe we will
calculate probabilities than usual way
by using conditional PDFs instead of
ordinary PDFs